aux représentations qui fondent les
relations sociales
alors pourquoi la martinique est pas
parce que j'avais une prof qui est un
petit peu quand je faisais mes études
dans les années 80 donc ça remonte au
loin qui faisait marcher ce qu'on
appelle le paradigme du lointain
l'anthropologie elle repose sur le grand
partage entre la sociologie d'un côté
qui s'occuperait des sociétés dites
développées à l'époque années 80 et puis
d'anthropologie des sociétés dites du
sud 2 comme on dit aujourd'hui ou en
voie de développement le lointain et
donc j'avais presque une injonction ma
prof d'anthropologie de l'époque de mots
que de travailler sur du lointain roma à
l'époque je travaillais sur du proche et
je travaillais notamment sur mais mes
propres racines qui sont celles des
landes des landes girondines de toute la
culture paysanne au tour des landes
girondines
mon grand père étant résignées résigné
c'est celui qui qui n'est pas résigné
mais qui extraient la résine et donc
j'avais un collègue
j'étais surveillant d'externat l'époque
et j'avais un collègue martinique est
pas très bavard un grand taiseux mais
j'ai quand même appris que la france
pratiqué l'esclavagé c'est pour ça que
je dis que c'est pas très glorieux pour
moi parce que je ne pensais pas que la
france pratique l esclavage pensé que
c'était plutôt les états unis voyage
étaient nés élevés au petit lait de la
république et la république pour moi
d'être là parce que j'avais une
vingtaine de jeux là je peux excuser
l'ignorance j'avais à peine 20 ans mais
d'autres que vous n'avez pas pris ça à
l'école ni au lycée queneau malin par
contre ma mère avait été très frappé par
le
le feuilleton racines réellement avait
beaucoup parlé mais vaut donc je
localise l esclavage aux états unis et
donc ça a été le début d'une grande
curiosité un déclic un déclic un déclic
n'est d'une ignorance donc je devrais
avoir honte mais voilà c'était le départ
et de faire marcher ou à l'injonction de
ma prof le paradigme du lointain et
alors qu'ils ont développé à l'époque ce
qu'on appelle anthropologie du proche
maintenant c'est à dire qu'on peut faire
de l'anthropologie partout dans le métro
dans les aéroports dans dans nos rues
dans nos foyers et l'idéal pour cette
discipline j'en profite et du coup je je
donne l'information nous avons fondé à
bordeaux avec justin daniel qui est de
l'université des antilles avec mon
regretté collègue anthropologue barish
van khê jamaïcain et moi-même en 2007
mais depuis 2004 nous l'avions mis en
place un programme franco jamaïcain de
formation de cycle lnd et dont
l'objectif était justement avec mon ami
barish va nous partagions une utopie qui
était de faire que cette discipline
d'anthropologie elle soit vraiment
croisés c'est à dire que nous n'ayons
plus cette relation de dissymétrie
coloniale dont je suis un exemple c'est
à dire que les pays occidentaux où les
pays européens étudient les pays du sud
et nous nous avions cette utopie
d'inverser ce rapport c'est à dire de
nom pas de l'inverser que faire chacun
sait tu dis chez soi mais qu' il y ait
des regards croisés que les jamaïcains
viennent étudier les français que les
martiniquais viennent étudier de lait
français hexagonaux selon les idées ou
les français voilà donc c'était eux nés
de cette de cette utopie d'un croisement
des regards qui fonctionne alors qu'ils
fonctionnent
oui bien que nous ayons plutôt des
doctorants puisque ce programme
maintenant à plus de 10 ans d'existence
donc a donné lieu à la formation de
jeunes docteurs on a dès la première
soutenance qui a eu lieu en mars cette
année
oui bah non le rapport est pas tout à
fait inversée mais l'interculturalité et
irriguer vraiment par ce programme c'est
un programme d'interconnaissance
d'apprentissage de l'interculturalité et
ça c'est un oui ça c'est le point le
plus positif de sel alors avant
d'arriver à aux événements de cette
combinaison de 1877 fameuse
d'insurrection du sud comment elle a été
rebaptisée un prêt par les historiens ou
les militants et puis deux de pouvoir
interpréter à ces événements comment
vous personnellement êtes-vous tombé sur
cette histoire cet événement qui a
secoué véritablement la martinique
pendant une semaine
monsieur jean diwo d'une semaine mais
pendant plusieurs mois plusieurs années
il ya eu des répercussions puisque on a
failli changer de système politique il
ya une répression sauvage des désertions
g et plats cab la justice en est mais
les banques 90 personnes ont été
condamnées au bagne en nouvelle
calédonie donc ce n'est pas rien nous y
reviendrons tout à l'heure mais qu'elle
a est ce un hasard est ce que c'est un
conseil comment avez vous fait pour
tomber sur l'histoire de l'insurrection
alors si je suis trop longue vous
interrompez parce que là ça ça remonte à
loin
disons que j'ai fait plusieurs séries de
travaux bon il ya maintenant 20 ans plus
de 20 ans que je suis chercheur au cnrs
donc j'ai fait une série de travaux dont
l'étude de la migration jamaïcaine au
royaume uni etc
et j'avoue que j'en avais un petit peu
un ras-le-bol de me retrouver enfin par
un ras-le-bol sais c'est pas le mot
c'est une interrogation réflexive c'est
plus le terme ça même si ça fait un peu
jargonneux c'est à dire un retour sur
moi même me disant que je vous le voulez
cesser d'être là outsiders étudiants les
personnes noires rejouant le ce fameux
rapport de dissymétrie cologna alors je
me suis dit je vais étudier chez moi je
vais revenir aux proches et je vais
revenir aux proches à bordeaux et étudie
la mémoire de l'esclavagé à bordeaux
puisque bordeaux est un ancien pas que
les bombes jusqu'à présent
en jeter un voile pudique s'ils ont leur
propre au passé qui en compte qui vient
enrichir cette ville d'autant que
d'autres sont toujours camouflé derrière
son rôle de leader du commerce colonial
donc ne pratiquant que très peu la
traite mais comme disent aux gérard pour
ya pas de différence entre des portes et
un africain et en déporté dissous un
déporté 500 milles dont bordeaux a fait
500 a été à la tête de cinq cents
expéditions négrières mais surtout
bordeaux a bâti sa fortune sur ce qu'on
appelle le commerçant droiture
donc c'est à dire lire elt bordeaux les
antilles et donc bah oui je me sens à
vous couper la parole parmi les
armateurs aux négociants bordelais qui
ont laissé des traces ici notamment
gradis examine leur exploitation d'une
habitation tantôt non
abbas compte aujourd'hui donc j'ai
étudié cette mémoire de l'esclavagé dans
les anciens ports négriers notamment au
royaume-uni puisque bordeaux est jumelée
avec bristol bristol un des plus grands
ports négriers après liverpool mêmes qui
a été avant liverpool à une certaine
époque et l'agent déduisait que la cette
mémoire de l'esclavagé qui arrivé
subitement dans l'espace public c'était
un moyen pour les minorités qui jusqu'à
présent et surtout dans la l'espace
politique français avait été invisible
de venir à visibilité est l'exemple en
est donnée par les élections municipales
de 2001 à bordeaux pour la première fois
il ya une liste municipale conduite par
un noir sénégal et dont la carrière
politique a été construite sur la
revendications mémorielles corps de
l'esclavagé voilà très bien c'est le
connaissait bien
donc le bon on va pas analyser la
posture de karfa diallo mais karfa
diallo est d'origine sénégalaise donc
c'est à rester un champ conflictuelle
antilles et africains etc
bon moi j'ai étudié tout ça et j'ai
étudié la conclusion que j'en tirais
c'est que cette catégorie mémoire de l
esclavage arrivée dans l'espace public
elle permettait une une venue à
visibilité des communautés et donc des
stratégies politiques et tout le monde a
le droit d'avoir des stratégies bowling
la stratégie politique n'est pas
c'est pas l'occident qui en a le
monopole donc c'est un peu mes
conclusions au même moment émerger un
courant qui est encore dominant
aujourd'hui nous sommes en phase
néoconservatrice en france on le voit
tous les jours malgré des changements
donc ce néo conservatisme s'exprimer
particulièrement chez les historiens qui
ont eu une riposte vis-à-vis des
revendications mémorielles de ceux
venant des anciens empires de l'ancien
empire colonial et notamment pierre nora
pierre noites et un de nos plus grands
historiens et pierre nora qui a publié
un ouvrage en 2008 où ils discréditent
complètement cette mémoire de
l'esclavagé en disant qu'elle a été une
mémoire inventé une mémoire factice qui
fait régresser l'histoire française qui
ce qu'ils réclament
là la notion enfin l'application de la
notion de crime contre l'humanité on est
quand même après la loi taubira mais que
c'est un anachronisme et il dit même que
c'est une unnim une humanité différente
de la nôtre qui réclame ce donc ce set
ap enfin cette désignation en tant que
crime contre l'humanité d' aveuglement
voilà qui ce qui est très grave parce
que c'est un différentialisme raciale
donc moi je me suis dit à ce moment là
mais je nourris ans avec mon analyse qui
parle de la mémoire de l'esclavagé comme
d'une catégorie de discours qui sert une
une action politique je donne du grain à
moudre à ces gens là donc je me suis dit
je vais arrêter de travailler là dessus
sur le côté d'actualisation dans le
champ politique et publique pour
m'intéresser à nouveau alors moi qui ne
voulais pas revenir sur des sujets très
anthropologique je me suis dit il faut
absolument travailler sur cette mémoire
de l'esclavagé sur ce qu'elle est
réellement et revenir vers les antilles
pour aller puiser au plus près de la
matrice sk la jst ce qu'est la mémoire
en quelque sorte décrypter l'histoire de
bandeaux ou de la france coloniale du
temps du commerce colonial à partir non
seulement de là où vous êtes là vous
êtes un situer physiquement
géographiquement culturellement bon dos
et cet espace coloniale
en fait cet ancien espace coloniale et
faire le chemin inverse pour aller jusqu
ici notamment d' american aux caraïbes
voilà exactement c'était faire le oui le
chemin inverse retourner au plus près de
la matrice au plus près de la matrice
pour voir ce qu'ils en sont les eric et
qui vivent encore dans cette matrice qui
reconduite sous des formes qui ne sont
pas les mêmes bien évidemment mais qui
sont encore réactualisé qu'est ce qu'il
y a comme souvenir de l'esclavagé
qu'est-ce qui lia comme mémoire de
l'esclavagé alors le problème c'est que
je me suis retrouvé entre deux
difficultés énormes
d'un côté donc l'économie morale du
soupçon ce que j'ai appelé l'économie
morale du soupçon c'est à dire ce fief
qui dit que cette mémoire elle a été
subitement un vente etc et de l'autre
l'anthropologie elle-même de la caraïbe
qui a desservi
l'idée qu'il puisse y avoir une mémoire
de l'esclavagé parce que l'anthropologie
de la caraïbe
elle elle s'intéresse à savoir est ce
que oui ou non les esclaves ont pu
conserver un héritage africain
elle est structurée autour de cette
problématique elle n'est pas structurée
autour de caisse que l' esclavage a
laissé comme mise en récit comme comme
représentation qu'ils puissent être
aujourd'hui dans l'action opération
surtout qu'ils puissent être le
l'héritage que enfin l'héritage ce que
l'on porte en soi et qui explique
l'action d'aujourd'hui c'est à dire que
nous ne sommes tous des êtres de mémoire
nous avons tous un passé et
l'anthropologie ne s'est pas intéressée
à salles étaient divisés entre trois
thèses qui avait un rapport à l
esclavage mais sans mettre l'esclavagé
en tant que objets à étudier mémorial
soit l'africanité c'est à dire ce sont
des descendants d'africains les antilles
et et ils ont gardé une mémoire de
l'afrique
c'était aussi pour ça c'est de remonter
jusqu'aux vite sa rom antara
et puis il ya tout tout ce qui a donné
lieu à tous ces courants infruts centric
70 euros pour les situer dans le temps
dont il continue le débat est toujours
là
à ce moment là je vais beaucoup plu à
beaucoup peu avant avec les écrits des
risques aux vitz qui remonta aux années
40 si je ne fais pas erreur dans pour
herskowitz oui on a emmené dans un
vraiment au des obeaux des bûches
glacées melville sks cowitz américain
élèves de bois ce qui crée cette
anthropologie
au début il dit qu'il ya un an il n'y a
plus de traces de l'afrique quand ils
étudient les quartiers américains quand
ils voient les noirs américains dans les
grandes villes il ya plus d'afrique
et puis va il fait un voyage en haïti et
là il se dit non non il ya vraiment de
l'afrique dans la dans la diaspora dans
la ds pour africaine et de là découle il
est le premier en fait il y en avait
d'autres aussi des intellectuels bien
évidemment afro américains mais avec la
ségrégation leurs savoirs a été mal
connu qui ont bien sûr on peut pas même
parler de marcus garvey 1 qui qui se
réclame et de l'afrique
c'était déjà là donc cette thèse la
deuxième thèse c'est la créolisation ou
la créolité
c'est un mélange c'est un mélange mais
on parle pas d esclavage dedans on dit
que c'est un mélange le l'esclavagé a
donné un mélange mais qu'est-ce que
kelkoo ou et la mémoire de cet esclavage
en ce mélange de croître le concept
voilà on n'est pas au coeur de cette
problématique on est au coeur de décrire
des mécanismes qui font qu'on est plus
africain on est plus européen on est
créole et puis la troisième thèse qui a
été extrêmement vive et peut-être même
je dire encombrante dans les antilles
françaises c'est la thèse de
l'aliénation c'est-à-dire il ya plus
rien les esclavages à tous la mine et il
n'y a plus rien il ya plus de créations
qu'on n'est plus il n'y a même pas de
créolisation il ya une incomplétude
indéniablement et ça ça a été très fort
aux antilles françaises donc ça se forme
à trois thèses qui se sont affrontés ou
pas affronter mais en tout cas sur le
champ droit qui sont qu'à une vise une
une vie parallèle si je puis dire et
nous avons
des deux côtés de l'atlantique si je
puis dire un peu de mal à alors donc
disparaît la mémoire est alors moi quand
j'avais la trouver alors c'est pour en
revenir à l'insurrection du sud et à
votre question
j'ai simplement postuler au départ que
puisqu'il n'y avait pas de mémoire dite
en moi j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour
les écrits d'edouard glissant je pouvais
pas concevoir qu'un edouard glissant
puisse s'être trompé en disant que nous
avions nous étions en présence d'une
mémoire non sédimenter d'une non
histoire d'un vide mémorielle et c'est
donc moi j'ai pris ça au sérieux et j'ai
pensé qu' il n'y avait pas ce qu'on
appelle de la mise en récit c'est à dire
un récit que l'on transmet de génération
en génération pour dire mon arrière
arrière grand père était esclave sur tel
plantations il s'y passe et telle chose
et d'idées rail aurait pas eu cette
transmission et du coup je me disais à
la place de ça c'est pas possible un
peuple ne vit pas sans mémoire
il ya peut-être des intellectuels ou des
cherchant comme glissant qui disent qu'
il n'y a pas eu de transmission donc ça
veut dire que peut-être qu'il n'y avait
rien à transmettre
voilà on est honni dans la thèse du de
la tabula rasa
on aimait me glissant et quand même
beaucoup plus complexe que ça lorsqu'il
parle de traces il a remis la voilà il
va changer après son but mais voilà et
puis il ya deux périodes glissant tienne
moi je parle de cette du discours
antilles et il ya celles qui va suivre
qui est la tesla la période de la
créolisation qui est quand même un petit
peu plus plus optimiste et il ya surtout
cette notion de traces chez glissant
c'est là que la mémoire ne se donne pas
à lire comme elle pourrait se donner à
lire dans les nations européennes avec
l'un des six national voilà et donc je
postulais qu'en lieu et place de cette
mémoire narrative on va l'appeler comme
ça en mémoire du récit mémoire du
souvenir qui est relaté il y a une
mémoire qu'on appelle dans notre jargon
incorporé c'est à dire qu'on réagit
c'est une mémoire à la foire est active
et agissante qu'on avait les
comportements les attitudes des pensées
des pensées positives et général qui
sont dans nos gènes mais qu'ils sont
qu'on s'identifie vécu émotionnel qui se
transmet et je pense que les conflits
sur le lieu qui le parlent le mieux de
cette mémoire incorporé sterp tout
conflit et vous savez certainement mieux
que moi combien les conflits sont
récurrents quasi tous les jours y
compris en avant un séjour aussi encore
d'accord sur les contrats aidés
oui pour un motif politique complètement
différents mais avec toujours les mêmes
ressorts la revendication de l'égalité
la revendication du droit la
communication d'être comme tout le monde
la revendication de la dignité
depuis un siècle et demi d'histoire en
fait de cela voilà alors moi j'ai
postulé que ces conflits récurrents et
est le lieu où se remettait en scène se
rejouer le rapport maître esclave c'est
à dire que chacun de ces conflits et
irriguée par la dualité
hélas la douleur le souvenir de la
douleur et de la souffrance d'un
conflits non réglés entre maîtres et
esclaves et qui est au fondement des
rapports sociaux martiniquais on
pourrait le dire pour d'autres
situations sauf que quand même la
martinique est exceptionnel dans le sens
où elle continue à contenir dans un
espace insulaire en face à face quand
même assez profonds entre des groupes
qui sont descendants de descendants de
descendants de mettre descendants
d'esclaves
même si on ne veut pas simplifier on est
obligé de un moment donné de constater
qu'il ya c'est une une exception une
continuité de ce point de vue là donc
j'ai choisi des unités de conflit j'ai
choisi une la plus ancienne j'ai voulu
après la période donc après l' esclavage
puisque c'étaient des souvenirs d
esclavage qui m'intéressait donc j'ai
choisi de l'insurrection du sud pour ces
raisons là ensuite la sphère beauregard
qui par exemple et ensuite le dernier
conflit j'ai pas choisir j'aurais pu
choisir le groupe accor le etc
non j'ai choisi le mouvement
d'occupation des terres qui démarre en
et qu'ils continuent dans les années
2000 qui est donc l'occupation par des
agriculteurs noirs des terres des blancs
beke donc avec ces unités de conflit
j'ai travaillé sur le souvenir de l'
esclavage et ô surprise l'insurrection
du sud m'a révélé ce que je ne cherchais
plus puisque jeter dans le dans l'idée
qu'il n'y avait pas cette mémoire
narrative
or comme j'avais assez travaillé assez
vite en fait ce qui est assez rare est
le temps c'est quelque chose de très
précieux en recherche
il me restait du temps pour aller à la
recherche un peu cherché les à l'éguille
dans la botte de foin chercher les
descendants des insurgés aidés je
connaissais des noms par les actes du
procès par les travaux de gilbert pago
armand nicolas qui ont été mes
prédécesseurs illustres et je n'aurais
jamais pu faire ce travail s'ils
n'avaient pas fait le leur avant et donc
j'ai retrouvé les descendants des
insurgés de 10 de 1870 et c'est avec eux
que j'ai pu postuler
cette mémoire narrative puisque eux
transporte un discours un récit de
l'épopée de leur taille et de leurs
aïeux et la raconte aujourd'hui sans
interférence pour certains de la source
écrite puisque certains de mes
interlocuteurs créolophones dans les
j'ai fait mon étude jusqu aux années
2009 à caen et l'ouvragé sorti en 2007
des cendres qui ont pu eux mêmes avoir
une bonne une bonne
d'après vous deux pas de bons souvenirs
mais c'est passé militaire altérer ou au
contraire assez complet assez exhaustif
de ce qui s'est passé
alors c'est pas souvenir dont on va
pouvoir dire on va le comparer à la
source écrit évidemment parce que la
source écrite est terrible c'est les
actes du procès de 1860
on sent son pays juge l'événement de
1870 bon après il ya eu bien sûr les
délibérations du conseil privé il ya
tout d'autres sources mais la source
principale pour étudier l'insurrection
ce sont ces fameux acte du procès qui
ont une part mystérieuse parce que on
sait pas trop si ce sont des actes de
procès ou juste la publication des
principales séance dans le journal les
colonies il ya un mystère autour de ça
mais c'est mon but n'était pas de
comparer le le discours par rapport aux
actes les actes sont ici on noie
j'espère le temps d'en parler parce que
c'est ce qui fait de l'insurrection un
événement majeur c'est que le le procès
lui-même va poser les bases d'une
nouvelle d'un nouveau régime politique
qui soit disant républicain mais qui va
plutôt être une république coloniale et
raciale
en tout cas la république en france
puisque c'est la défaite de napoléon iii
mais qui tarde à se mettre en place en
martinique mais juste un petit retour en
arrière en flash back pour parler
français pour rappeler ce qu'était cette
insurrection du sud
rapidement le fait déclencheur en
complément la parole si je me trompe
c'est une altercation puis une bagarre
entre fonctionnaires français d'une part
i jeune commerçant noir françois lubin
d'autre part qui se déroule qui se passe
mal et lubin va porter plainte à la
gendarmerie parce qu'ils estimaient
avoir été humiliés et justement par ce
fonctionnaire qui passait à cheval dans
un chemin qui a ordonné à l'humain de
dégager qui ne voulait pas et deux
hommes se sont présentés et l'autre
l'art sauvagement labatut lubin est
débouté mais finalement quelques temps
plus tard il va se venger en infligé une
sévère correction à son agresseur et
lui-même il est condamné à cinq ans de
prison ce qui n'est cinq ans de bagne à
cinq ans de bagne oui merci de la
précision ce que la population refuse
catégoriquement
et c'est de là que commencent les
premières escarmouches contre la
gendarmerie contre les bâtiments publics
et au fur et à mesure quelques heures si
je puis dire dans quelques jours cette
insurrection
elle est cantonnée aussi parce que la
ministre équivalent de l'armée pour
aller vite fait un barrage entre
fort-de-france robert pour contenir
cette rébellion dans le sud c'est
pourquoi on l'a appelé d'ailleurs à
l'insurrection du sud et non pas les
instructions
le north atlantic dans le centre ou dans
dans le nom caraïbes et donc à ce
moment-là l'alarmé la milice on reprend
reprend la situation en main des
dizaines de personnes sont poursuivies
des condamnations à mort sans prononcer
des gens sont fusillés les condamnés à
mort sont fusillés au jardin des clients
à fort de france et il ya 90 personnes
qui sont condamnées aubagne qui à ce
moment là existent en nouvelle calédonie
donc une nouvelle pression assez sévère
et les historiens ou les autres volant
comme rousseau cfd minutes du procès
pour voir effectivement quelques intel
les rapports de force à ce moment là
qu'est ce qu'on peut apprendre
j'allais dire à ce moment là de ma géant
sur ce qui se passe en martinique
je rappelle que nous sommes 22 ans après
l'abolition de l'esclavagé
voilà alors d'une part oui c'est la
sphère du bain lubin qui est le
déclencheur c'est l'étincelle toute
révolte à une étincelle il y à une
révolte jumelles à la même époque
1865 en jamaïque il c'est extrêmement
intéressant de comparer les deux corées
vols sont exactement les mêmes causes
produisent les mêmes causes les mêmes la
même révolte la même étincelle kazim
accueil quasi la même étincelle s'éteint
le le cousin du leader paul google du
leader de la glace de l'insurrection de
morrone bay s'appelle mourad b qui va
dans qui va chercher son cheval sur la
propriété d'un blanc parce que son
cheval est allé là il n'avait pas le
droit de fouler le sol du blanc donc il
a été condamné
et là c'est la même chose il est
condamné injustement lors lubin lui il
est condamné à cinq ans de bagne mais à
la même époque
hélas ce soit nicolas soit pas go qui
cite cet exemple à la même époque un
blanc et condamné cinq mois pour avoir
tué un noir
donc c'est déjà un mécontentement
plus qu'un mécontentement c'est une
frustration énorme et une colère et
c'est ça prépare le terrain mais le
terrain vous avez dit à plusieurs
reprises en a failli c'est un
basculement changé de statut et c'est
moi d'après ce que je connais de
l'insurrection je n'en suis pas si sûr
que ça c'était pas un basculement
c'était une république une vraie
république que les insurgés voulaient
quand la longueur savait que la
république allait arriver
la république la surrection elle démarre
le jour de la proclamation de la
république le jour de la programmation
de la troisième république
elle est accueillie avec deux cris mort
à coder vive la république manquement à
rodez qui te le dit elle assiste à ces
sommes au procès de l'ubs a donc ça
c'est celui qui a beaucoup pesé pont que
la condamnation soit voilà dit donc côté
il incarne et l'âge moi c'est mon
hypothèse principale qui vient notamment
de l'attitude de tels cas le chef
insurrectionnelle qui va à plusieurs
reprises on retrouve en filigrane dans
les actes du procès alertées les
autorités de sa peur que les blancs se
les se retourne contre les noirs à la
faveur de la proclamation de la
république parce que il y a des
conservateurs chez les blancs qui ne
veulent absolument pas de la république
donc voyez on est dans une ambiguïté est
ce que c'est un projet nationaliste je
crois qu'on ne saura jamais il y a mais
que ce soit un pour un projet d'égalité
nu par une profonde pulsions d'égalité
mû par une une connaissance très fine de
skins démocratie ça je pense qu'on peut
le dire avec les traces qui nous reste
est aussi la mémoire qui s'est
constituée à partir de la connaissance
que les descendants aujourd'hui on de
lait des agissements de leurs aïeux
corps où on retrouve cette pulsion
d'égalité cette pulsion de liberté on
veut bien la république mais on ne veut
plus de la hiérarchie des races et on ne
veut plus de cette suprématie raciale et
ça sent le retrouve en analysant et
c'est ce contre quoi va se mobiliser
le tribunal et faire de ce procès un
acte de fondation d'une république tout
à fait particulière une république ne
concevra pas une égalité raciale à ce
qu'il dira qu'elles existent parce qu'on
peut faire un parallèle entre la fin de
la période immédiatement postérieure à
l'abolition de l'esclavagé où les colons
ont été indemnisées directement ou
indirectement de la dépossession de
leurs esclaves qui sont devenus des
travailleurs salariés et il y a eu aucun
blanc qui a été tué ou pourchassés en
tout cas martinique il n'y a pas eu de
démenti n'y a pas eu de révolte contre
les blancs contre les békés contre les
fonctionnaires de passage contre l'armée
la gendarmerie
tout s'est passé si vous voulez pas dans
le calme c'est pas vrai qu'en tout cas
il n'y a pas eu cette révolte que
certains craignaient à l'époque en en
1870 22 ans après l'abolition esclavage
certains peuvent se demander si cette
révolte langue qui n'a pas eu lieu à ce
moment là ne se déroule pas là
1170 non seulement comme certains békés
quand certains fonctionnaires de passage
mais également contre les symboles des
institutions dépasser des décisions qui
ne sont pas encore tout à fait
démocratique ou républicaine alors ce
qui se passe en 48 il ya quand même
parce que ces orgies le nom m'échappe
malheureusement j'ai une très mauvaise
mémoire travailleurs sur la mémoire
c'est pas très glorieux il y à un blanc
tué parce que c'est très important de
voir que les l'histoire martiniquaise et
scandé à plusieurs paires de massacre
qui se déroule sous ce delà de la même
manière un massacre de blanc par
plusieurs protagonistes avec de la même
manière avec le coûteux là plusieurs
coups de couteau la du de l'eau pimenté
mis sur les plaies etc
c'est la même chose pour coder alors ça
on peut l'expliquer et puis y aura aussi
le becquet je pense que le dernier
massacre de békés ces de fabrique c'est
en 1951 voilà voilà donc ce qu'il se
passe c'est que andy en 1848 oui on
croit que les compteurs c'est une
expression de ma collègue myriam cottias
les compteurs de l'histoire sont remis à
zéro en amnistie tout le monde mais ya
quand même un blanc qui est ce que je
voulais vous dire est blanc comme il y
aura en 1810 on amnistie tout le monde
on remet les compteurs de l'histoire à
zéro et on recommence à zéro ce qui va
se passer en 1870 c'est qu'on a déjà mis
les compteurs à zéro et que là on va
faire penser qu'ils sont à zéro et que
l'on est dans un contexte d'égalité mais
effectivement les insurgés le savent ils
ne sont pas ils vivent encore dans des
conditions dans celle cher dira que ce
sont les cc les mêmes conditions que
pendant l'esclavagé
il parlera de retour de quasi retour à
l'esclavagé parce que il y a une en le
second empire
le second empire qui a obligé au retour
de la main d'oeuvre sur les plantations
au puisque ce dont on avait besoin c'est
terrible à dire il y avait certainement
un humanisme dans l'abolition on peut
pas dire la chaîne chers et clins pas
humaniste mais en même temps il y avait
des intérêts économiques
on était en pole en état
les habitations les exploitations les
sucreries étaient devenus les sucres hot
des fameux sucre hotte était devenu
périmés c'était donc dans une révolution
industrielle
donc cette modernisation à marche forcée
depuis dix ans le système économique
après la bolivie ce qui se passe c'est
terrible à dire mais c'est que les
esclaves ne sont plus rentables parce
qu'il faut les nourrir parce qu'il faut
et ce n'est plus adapté au système
donc il faut une main d'oeuvre salariée
qui va pouvoir être mobile venir pour la
coupe de la canne venir pour là c'est la
fabrication du sucre et elle coûtera
moins cher que de rester à demeure comme
du temps de l'escale c'est terrible à
dire mais non c'est praia da luz et ce
qui se passe c'est que les anciens
esclaves lui n'ont qu'une aspiration et
ça c'était mes premières études à mes
études de thèse de doctorat c'est la
terre à voir la terre et c'est ce qui
est au fondement de cette composante si
riche
la composante pour moi la plus riche de
l'histoire martiniquaise qui est le
monde des mornes le monde de la petite
paysannerie vivrières donc j'ai eu la
chance de connaître mes premiers voyages
mes premiers séjours de terrain dans les
années 80 les la fin de l'existence
parce qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas dire
qu'on retrouve vraiment les expressions
tout a été mis aux normes les marchés le
marché de saint pierre c'est c'est d'une
tristesse de voir cette mise en demeure
voilà ce marché de saint-pierre
extrêmement vivant et donc ce qui se
passe en 1870 c'est que les hyènes qu'on
ya une conscience de critiques qui est
d'éveiller là pour dire que les
conditions ne sont plus acceptables les
coder est impliqué dans plusieurs
petites affaires il doit de l'argent à
un tel il a pas payé le cheval qu'il a
acheté un autre il ya deux ou trois
protagonistes qui on a reproché des
choses à il n'a pas payé un de ses
serviteurs
on l'appelle toujours m et dans le
procès alors qu'on est en train
le président déclame sans arrêt et
proclame sans
et que les insurgés sont en train de
réveiller ce que 1848 avait endormi de
conflits des races qu'il n'existe plus
il donne la jonction aux accusés parce
qu'on les appelle les accusés car ils
sont déjà ils sont déjà accusé un et on
les appelle palais et donne injonction
d'appeler les blancs les maîtres et il y
à un avocat extrêmement courageux qui
s'appelle barre du riz qui va dire au
président du tribunal mais vous êtes en
train de dire que les hiérarchie des
races n'existent plus mais vous nous
parler sans arrêt de blanc de noir et
donc la cdc très courage de cet avocat
mais on ne sait plus qui devient il
disparaît des actes du procès donc je
pense qu'il a été
voilà donc oui ce sont si vous voulez on
ne peut plus en 1870 faire ce que l'on
avait fait en 1848 c'est à dire faire
penser qu'on peut redémarrer sur quelque
chose de neuf
puisqu'on a déjà eu la preuve que 10 848
n'avait pas c'est un peu ce que vous
dites en même temps un navet n'avait pas
réussi de paris de fonder une société
nouvelle c'est exactement la même
déception qu aux états unis avec la
reconstruction
ah là là que la période de la
reconstruction qui est un échec total
ma la période qui succède à l'abolition
est un échec total
et c'est peut-être qu'ils vont à 6 ans j
deux décennies plus tard mais après les
événements après l'insurrection du sud
c'était même sur bellion populaire qui a
eu lieu en 1170 mené entre autres par
rosalie pendant alumina sophie jeune
lacaille tels gains bolivar dont on dit
qu'ils étaient des chefs unités en
d'autres cas des chefs politiques en
fait il y avait
minimum d'organisation même si c'est le
peuple qui se soulever spontanément
seriez vous tenté de dire que c'était
une rébellion organisée contrôler ou au
contraire elle avait quand même 141 ans
de spontanéité ce qui peut expliquer qu'
elle n'a duré qu'une semaine finalement
alors en jamaïque
elle est extrêmement organisés autour de
chef paul google et william gordon
williams gordon qui joue un rôle plus
périphériques c'est un mulâtre 1 qui
quitte à kingston au moment des
événements là on peut on aller vraiment
l'épreuve du nord de ce que peut être
une organisation et ça passe par le
religieux parce que c'est des mouvements
baptiste black baptiste ou native
baptiste qui sont différents de baptiste
laxiste et puis des baptistes
britannique mary là on voit vraiment une
organisation dans le cas de
l'insurrection du sud - j'ai analysé
d'une autre manière en fonction d'onde
et des sources et de ce que j'ai pu
aussi collecté dans la mémoire orale et
peut-être dire je fais la pub du couple
c'est vrai que j'ai tendance à l'oublier
que dans le livre que j'ai écrit s'est
développée et notamment au sila la
trajectoire
le profil des des protagonistes j'ai
réussi grâce aux sources à l'appui à
cette convergence entre l'oralité et
l'écrit et ses archives à faire des pros
au dépôt retrait des insurgés donc les
plus connus bien évidemment mais
d'autres dont je le signale donc dans
cet ouvrage parce que j'en fais jamais
la pub et mon éditeur va peut-être me
fait remarquer donc l' esclavage dit
souvenir à la mémoire et donc ce propos
que je tiens ces deux alors c'est pas de
dire que c'est désorganisés mais c'est
de dire qu'il n'ya pas eu à
l'organisation un camp lacaille tel gars
et un camp insurrectionnel à la régal et
de là tout se déroule
il ya eu une multitude de bandes on
appelait on les appelait les bandes
c'est à dire des groupes de 500 600
personnes 300 qui étaient réunies et
certains le au cours du procès dirons
nous n'avons pas de nous n'avions pas de
chef
et certains même ne refuserons d'obéir à
la caille ne seront pas d'accord avec la
caille et ça ça ne veut pas dire que
c'est le bazar
pour moi c'est typique c'est typiquement
significatif de ce que jacky dahomay le
philosophe guadeloupéens à peine cette
pulsion d'égalité c'est à dire que le
chef le chef ne doit pas être le chef il
ya toujours une méfiance à l'égard du
chef et chacun est autorisé à être chef
un moment donné et on le voit même les
membres du tribunal ils se perdent
parce que je pense que là là c'est la
culture qui est porté par les anciens
esclaves et profondément irrigué par la
connaissance intime de ce que peut être
le pouvoir et l'exercice du pouvoir sur
l'autre
en somme les filles on s'oblige ensemble
et fille du leader du jeu le pouvoir est
disséminée il y a plusieurs bandes
plusieurs chefs de bande qui seront chef
un jour et le lendemain ce sera un autre
et ça je crois que c'est très très
important et je ne je ne le met pas sous
le le compte du désordre
ce n'est pas le désordre c'est contre
l'ordre
c'est viscéralement contre la violence
que peut re que peut représenter
l'exercice du pouvoir affirmant qu'ils
n'ont pas de désunion mais peut-être que
d'inefficacité à terme non pas que c'est
la grande question parce que quand même
pendant une semaine il fallait tenir
tête à la ministre et les chiens avec
les soeurs williams il y avait un modèle
de caen organisé c'est vrai que tel gala
caille c'était un camp organisé il ya
les deux modèles un la multiplicité
supporte donc d'avoir des choses
contradictoires en son sein le camp de
la régal était organisée mais avec
certains il ya des des accusés qui dira
que bon bah il a il a obéi à la caille
mais avec certaines
alors non pas pour des délations de la
callas mais y cite l'exemple d'ailleurs
c'est très courageuse qui dit dis vous
me demandez vous monsieur le président
du tribunal de m'agenouiller qu'est ce
que vous croyez que je vais faire avec
la menace que vous fait peser sur moi
j'aime agenouillé et vous feriez pareil
et il dit que quand parce que le
président du tribunal lui lit mais
pourquoi vous êtes prêté au rituel du
bain puisque la caille faisait baigner
les dés les personnes qui étaient avec
lui pour les prémunir pour les protéger
de manière magique et caetera et donc
lui dit qu'il a fait parce que bon mais
pas avec eux cette cet esprit critique
et méfiant et sachant que ben il y avait
un lieu de pouvoir lamont val d'hérens
on va jouer avec on va le détourner
voyez bien il ya toujours et je pense
que véritablement il ya beaucoup d'
analyse maintenant qui convergent pour
voir dans la culture antillaise
cette connaissance aussi profonde de ce
qu'est l'exercice du pouvoir pour y voir
toujours c'est pour ça qu'on dit que
c'est un de mes collègues dit que ce
sont des cultures anarchique au sens
politique du terme est l'expression la
plus explicite qui nous en est donnée
c'est dans le mouvement au certes
galvaudé folkloriser qu'est le rasta le
mouvement rastafari et qui est pourtant
celui qui verbalisent le mieux ce que
l'on colmant on conçoit quelle est la
conception du pouvoir dans les sociétés
antillaises et c'est à dire que
l'autorité elle est reconnue dans la
personne elle n'est pas reconnue dans
l'eau d'une personne dans un chef voilà
elle n'en a reconnu 90 ans chacun c'est
la fameuse épistémologie bon je vous en
parle entre le détail du hay el raï à
nous ces jeux plus je le nous c'est
toujours deux individualités et il ya
tout le rasta talk qui est le fameux
langage rasta qui joue avec les mots et
par exemple une assemblée on dit pas
assemblés ont dit à y ressembler c'est
ce qui est tout à fait significative le
mans de jeu c'est un rassemblement des
jeux voilà et c'est parce que l'autorité
en milieu antilles et elle est placée
dans la personne en premier c'est elle
et le chacun fait ses affaires
c'est tout à fait ça c'est aussi une
idée
stration de cette autorité placé dans
l'individu alors je parle peut-être pour
une période qui ça je sais pas si c'est
encore valable encore de viscéralement
actuellement mais je serais tenté de
dire que oui oui oui encore des traces
un peu partout dans la carré mais on en
ignore également
alors pour revenir à la presse septembre
1870 c'est une dépression assez sévères
comme vous l'a vous l'avais dit à
l'instant un procès comme animal je veux
pas dit au magistrat n'est pas positif
d'un procès très important qui est
impossible ducati l'éducatif oppressif
équipe aux actes oui magistrats vous
pouvez me dire alors maintenant vous
êtes une chance quelqu'un qui va à la
rencontre des sources avancent appels
des personnes comme vous l'avez tout
salon les descendants de ces insurgés
s'en sent 434 en quarante ans après vous
allez dans les livres vous à vous allez
dans les documents écrits les minutes du
procès des actes du procès mais il ya
des interprétations militante également
et quelle est la part que l'on peut
faire comment comprenez vous ces
interprétations que l'on peut faire de
l'histoire en général de ces phénomènes
historiques entre la parole du militant
et la parole de l'historien
peuvent-elles se rejoint se rejoindre
tel nécessairement se parler se
communiquer entre elles ces deux paroles
c'est de savoir de cette amputation si
je peux dire alors bon d'une part la jce
l'état je suis pas exempte de mes
propres posture moi je me protège je le
disais hier au cours de la conférence la
de l'atrium de l'idéologique entre
guillemets par le choix de mes modèles
théoriques
moi je travaille des modèles théoriques
de philosophes de mais je travaille sur
la domination donc on pourrait très bien
imaginer que je fais de l'opinion non
parce que je travaille avec des outils
conceptuels qui ont été eux-mêmes
travailler et c'est pour démontrer
démontré ce qu'est la domination alors
après le champ idéologique qu'il s'en
empare j'ai envie de presque dire ce
n'est pas mon affaire ce n'est pas c'est
mon affaire à partir du moment où je
continue à travailler sur la donation
voilà alors je ne veux pas dire que je
suis apolitique absolument pas pas du
tout je n'aurais pas fait le choix de
travailler sur la domination si j'étais
apolitique mais je je je
j'ai travaillé avec les indépendantistes
je travaille avec les gens du mime
puisque la rivière pilote je travaille
avec le gars a mal ça je travaille avec
eux toutes ces personnes avaient des
relations
oui mais c'est plus que des personnes
ressources et des personnes avec qui je
suis en relation et je n'ai jamais eu à
être ai je le réclame
je ne suis mais même si hier soir
j'étais invitée par la ctn le président
de la ctm et ans alfred marie jeanne
je réclame mon et je pense que je tiens
là dessus à ma monde plus que mon
autonomie mon indépendance de pensée et
ma conférence ea hier étaient pour dire
délocalisons l'insurrection du sud n est
pas pilotine elle doit appartenir à
l'histoire de l'empiré colonial français
parce que la plus belle preuve qu on
apporterait de la réussite de ce procès
ce serait dans redoubler les
conséquences
en en faisant un événement localisé
alors que puisque ce procès était fait
pour réduire cette insurrection cède ce
désir d'égalité raciale à la transfigure
en affaires criminelles contre codé on
en a pas trop parlé un pionnier une
société qui n'a plus de hiérarchie des
races et que mais malgré ça on va
protéger la hiérarchie existantes
donc tout ça c'est un riche
d'enseignements et ça doit rentrer dans
l'histoire globale de l' empire colonial
et mon rendement et est rentrée depuis
fort longtemps dans l'histoire de
l'empiré colonial britannique il n'y a
pas un historien aujourd'hui qui ne
connaît pas mon rendement et qui a des
colloques internationaux là-dessus et
c'est la même insurrection alors
pourquoi l'une est resté dans le silence
et une affaire presque folklorique et
l'autre une affaire qui est connu comme
exemplaire des rapports sociaux sous le
régime alors je vous propose de vous
inviter à nouveau dans 120 ans une fois
que l'histoire de la sélection du site
de l'antique sera entré dans l'histoire
de lampions colonial français en tout
cas je vous remercie infiniment à
christine si wallon d'avoir échangé avec
nous sur ce sujet ô combien et qu'une
aujourd'hui dans cette émission face à
la première réalisée aujourd'hui par
quelqu'un qui est très attentif au monde
rastafari je veux parler de rose et
kaliste merci à bientôt
merci à vous merci beaucoup au revoir
[Musique]